I think the whole house will agree that
this is truly a truly shocking incident
my thoughts and all thoughts and
condolences are with the victims and
their loved ones at this utterly
terrible time and I'm sure the whole
house will also convey their condolences
at this sad time while the nationalities
of the victims are not yet known I have
asked my officials to work closely with
the investigation
providing all assistance we can in these
horrific circumstances
shortly before 1:40 a.m. today we
received reports that a number of people
have been found inside a Laurie's
container at the water glade industrial
park on Eastern Avenue in Gray's we
believe the lorry is from Bulgaria and
came into the UK through Holly Head on
the 19th of October emergency services
attended but sadly all 39 people inside
the container had died early indications
suggest that one of these people was a
teenager the rest are believed to be
adults a murder investigation was
launched and the lorry driver a 25 year
old man from Northern Ireland was
arrested on suspicion of murder and
remains in police custody at this stage
we have not identified where the victims
are from or their identities and we
anticipate this could be a lengthy
process I would like to thank the local
community and in particular those who
have been directly affected by the
police cordon at the industrial site
thank you for your cooperation and I
appreciate the impact road closure will
have on businesses within the cordon I'm
unable to say at this stage how long the
cordon will be in place but please let
me reassure you that my offices and
partners will be doing everything they
can to release the scene as soon as
possible this is an absolute tragedy and
very sad day for Essex Police and the
local community we will continue to work
alongside many other partner agencies to
find out what led to these deaths I'd
like to appeal for anyone who has any
information to contact my offices at the
major investigation team on 101 or by
visiting our Essex Police website we
will update all of our channels as we're
able to but please appreciate we're in
the early stages of what is likely to be
a lengthy investigation see
not at this stage and obviously the
identification of the victims remains
our number one priority the scene what
led you to go to the scene to
investigate and we received a call from
the ambulance service taking us why were
they alerted to that I'm not sure that
information at this point in time not at
this point in time said it's the early
stages of the investigation but
obviously that will be a key line of
inquiry and as I've said if anyone's got
any information relating to that lorry
and its movement since entering the
country on the 19th of October then
please do contact us on 101 it's very
early its stages it's a complex scene
and we've got expert officers working
with partners at the scene to identify
it and the best way forward to do that
in terms of the identification of those
those and individuals not
you